so you mentioned made me re-listen to it
i'm a big fan of cat stevens you made me
re-listen to father and son
um i probably all sons have issues
to work through with their fathers
um this is and you said that you connect
with this song in particular i think uh
so you're a father now
uh what is it about the song that
connects with you for people let me let
me play it let me play a little bit
people should educate themselves on cat
stevens oh my gosh right in the pieces
the best the best people ride on the
beach
you think this is a hopeful a sad song
i hear it was hopeful i heard is a
loving father saying just what his son
needs to
to make a change
just relax
take it easy
you're still young
that's your fault
there's so much you have it's like that
calm wisdom
yeah there's time it wise
[Music]
i am old
but i'm happy and just the way he says i
like that should be a corny line but
it's not corny at all
look at me i'm older but i'm happy
to be calm
when you found
something going on yeah i mean the
simplicity there and and it yeah but
it's such a contrast with um
what's his name um
harry chapman with the the cats in the
cradle
uh which is like
the sadness of
so th this feels like there's a
a wise calm
connection between father and son right
with uh with casting the cradle i don't
know if you remember that song um
he learned to walk while i was away and
he was talking
before i knew it and as he grew he'd say
i'm gonna be like you dad you know i'm
gonna be like you and the idea of that
song is
that he does become like his dad
which is funny not something you said
uh
but in a different way you become too
busy to make that connection his dad was
too busy to make a connection with his
son
in a not a dramatic way in a very kind
of calm not strong way like you don't
right you just don't have time
uh you're you're busy at work you're
providing for the family and so on
there's connection but you don't really
get form that like depth of connection
and
then the father when uh when the son
shows up from college and all that kind
of stuff he doesn't spend any time with
the father he
all that and just the calm sadness of
that that we
we live we can live parallel lives and
never quite connect
and there is a little bit of that in
father and son with cat stevens too you
know like when this when the sun is
saying um
from the moment that i could talk i was
ordered to listen
i always i always remember listening to
that line feeling like
that really moved me but the beauty of
that song is it shows
it's kind of like the theme of what i
feel like we've talked about since the
second you got here which is something i
really like i don't know why it's such
an important theme in my life right now
but
the duality
of just understanding that you don't
understand someone else's situation
and there's truth to both sides
like there's truth to what the father is
saying to the son he's like saying these
things and he's like i'm looking out for
you i love you
take your time with these things if you
want to get married no you can like
these things will bring you and then the
son
saying listen like i i want to pave my
own path i want to do this like why are
you telling me this like
the son's not wrong because there's a
lot of parents who tell their kids what
to do and they're wrong and dependent
you know what i mean like
and they don't let the kid form the path
that they need to
but
should you not be a parent like you know
there's just changes
there's a
there's a thing it is annoying when
you're older
you get you could get to see people do
all the same things you could say well
this is
um this is a phase
and you'll see that this actually will
um end up in this way you can like
predict how the life unrolls and it's
very annoying for young people to hear
especially because it's probably going
to be true it's like no it's not going
to be like this
no maybe different but then you become
that person but that doesn't mean they
also
let them live that life right let them
make the mistakes
uh but they're not mistakes actually
they're
they're like
beautiful deviations from the
from the path that they end up on and
those
those make the path
you